ich wollte was soll die scheiße ich gibt
tipps wie du mein bruder reinkommst und
politik bekomme ich geld von mir das war
jetzt aber ich bin total blank
ja es ist mein problem herr zurück in
den herzen kommen zu einem neuen video
in dem ich heute mal einem wunsch von
euch nachgehen werde und zwar habe ich
letzten tagen öfters der wunsch von euch
in meinen insgesamt bekommen übrigens
insta hat er es gesagt dass ich mir mal
die hilfe der folge no money no fun i
anschauen soll und genau das machen wir
heute
wir werden kurz mal einen blick in die
beschreibung die story ist story christa
heimlicher schwarm von demnächst doch
leider hat sie beim schlechte karten
elisa die kleine schwester des
basketballspielers will deshalb auf die
sprünge helfen und dinis mit ihrem
bruder verkuppeln allerdings ist der
service team sonst für jeden tipp soll
deniz baris zahlen
also es geht darum dass ein mensch quasi
verkauft wird und der titel wie gesagt
no money no fun i ich verkaufe meinen
bruder alles klar
chelsea tritt erst mal also das ist
scheinbar die nächste auf der rechten
seite die in chris verliebt ist christus
hin berichtet er gerade basketball
spielt und ja wie soll ich euch sagen
heute die gute denise spürt die hitze
auf jeden fall sie spürt lied und zieht
sich beim anblick von christian krismer
[Musik]
ich habe 14 jährige die er zuschauen
okay leute kommentiert und mit eurem
alter das für mich interessieren kommt
im alten rhein neckar
das können wir nicht zeigen ich spiele
einfach mit dem mit diesen anders gehe
nicht schwitzt doch sonst nicht hat die
geniale strategie reinzugehen und ihn zu
fragen ob sie mitspielen kann
denise hast du auch im kopf wo willst du
damit spielen
da ist nicht mal spielt eine chance
gewartet ich mach das
okay leute jetzt mal durchschnaufen
bevor jetzt gleich der big points kommt
ich fühle mich wirklich ihre freundin
was die sinne
das ist wieder das verkehrsunfall sind
rum leute habe ich schon ein paar mal
gesagt meine hilfe wäldchens es ist wie
ein verkehrsunfall
man will ich hinschauen aber man muss
[Musik]
wir müssen versuchen blickfeld so gut
wie möglich zu bedenken okay ich habe
leider keine sonde verloren weil ich ein
vollidiot bin und alles verliere
übrigens auch letztens meine bose
qualcomm platz für 300 euro verlorenheit
da kann ich wieder eine klasse leistung
und jetzt gehts weiter
ich habe gesagt ich glaube kissen
das ist ja dass ich spüre wirklich den
physischen schmerz in meinem bauch
decker das also mit mir jemand da rein
geboxt sie geht einfach so dahin
kein mensch hat nach ihr gefragt oder
nach ihr gebeten oder die situation
überhaupt so aufgestellt dass sie was
rein gehen könnte
sie macht es trotzdem und nimmt auch mal
den ball weg das tut weh erzieher müssen
trainieren und sichtbare hemd das erste
spiel so gemeint aber okay wir haben das
gehört dass gerade dann ehre genommen er
hat gesagt no hitter nicht aber verpiss
dich du gestellt und sich so das ist
mein traum war toni wie was ist für sie
das ist mein traum
am 18 er ist geändert haben sich elisa
ähnlich sagt aber auch zu helfen okay er
hat zwar gesagt du alle milchkuh
verschwinde aus meinem blickfeld aber er
hat sagt die nächste allem also erkennt
mein name auf meine titten geglaubt
wahrscheinlich auch dann herzlich mehr
es so wird das nicht unbedingt neue
unterwäsche kaufen ein
[Musik]
das ist ekelhaft okay dass ich der erste
kopfhörer
wir haben schon kein bock mehr auf stopp
sollte sogar die hardware verabschiedet
sich schon okay die taschengeld tabelle
des jugendamtes bietet eltern eine gute
richtschnur für die bemessung der höhe
des taschengeldes bringt die taschengeld
tabelle des jugendamtes kindern auch bei
dass sie sich nicht wie komplette
blamagen verhalten sollen scheinbar
nicht was die taschengeld tabelle
regierung haben das aber scheinbar sehr
wohl bei bringt ist dass es egal ist ob
der eigenen schwarm zu einem sagt du
alte restmülltonne hau ab solange er den
vornamen sagt 30 euro sind gerade
nochmal so angemessen empfohlen werden
35 bis 45 euro im monat aber es kommt
natürlich immer darauf an wie viel geld
die familie insgesamt zur verfügung hat
es kommt natürlich immer darauf an ob er
den vornamen gesagt hat in dem satz in
dem er einen komplett die lte aber rita
also wenn ich jetzt übertreibe leute
will ich nicht so in diesem feld
einstimmen von wegen die person des
richters über die sich die coolsten klar
wird
hast du dich leute aber ich gehe vom mit
dem job von der sendung mit na also also
das bild auseinander dass christ kein
interesse an denise hat liegt weder an
taschengeld noch an den s p h
wahrscheinlich wäre hier weniger gerade
mehr gewesen
noch weniger klamotten in dem fall wäre
tatsächlich mehr mehr gewesen mehr
bewusstsein dafür was man in welchen
situationen bestenfalls sagen sollte und
in welchen situationen man einfach mal
die klappe halten sollte
[Musik]
es ist lisa ich weiß von christina
abgeholt das habe ich okay also dass die
gerade eben war nicht elisa sondern dass
wir jetzt gesehen dass die leser dass
die schwester von chris von ihrem
schwarm und jetzt gleich wird sich der
inhalt der folge offenbar in dem elisa
dem ich zu ihr sagt du juni pro nacht
mit meinem bruder bist du dabei die
leute wie wird unsere geschätzten genieß
das jetzt auffassen optional wird sie
sagen so weiter die hat er gar kein bock
auf mich ich glaube ich glaube ich habe
irgendwie ein bisschen was falsch
gemacht sollte vielleicht beim nächsten
mal anders auf die leute zu oder ob zb
perfekt zu sein noch perfekt gelaufen
wie er ich habe den typen selbst
[Musik]
naja da schon wieder so brok okay sagt
zu der schwester von diesem typen sowie
ich lasse es sein und dieser soll ja
okay gut 1 1 1 1 was macht sie kauft so
eine 40er packung von diesen oblaten eis
dingern oder was das ist von diesen
eiswaffel er ist mein bruder will
außerdem richtet auf 1000 meter denise
stell dich hinten an ok denise ich halte
sie gerne noch mal vor augen okay wir
haben hier den den emilio sacra ja den
elias m'barek von deutschland die arbeit
kommt auch aus deutschland aber fresser
dieser typ hat wirklich schlangen weise
frauen okay also da ist wirklich nicht
schlange dann kommt denise anders
ja ich bin auch gerne ich geb dir selbst
wieder mein bruder reinkommst echtes
willst du machen kannst du denn ich habe
die chance war ihm ja kleineren
veränderungen
sie freut sich so richtig was du willst
mir für eine eine leistung die jeder
andere mensch kostenlos machen würde
geld abnehmen
[Musik]
das ist also das umstyling also ja also
ich bin keine fashion youtube oder
irgendwas mit dem sinne leute aber für
mich sieht es so aus als wäre sie von so
lala outfit hinzu so lala outfit in
einer anderen farbe gegangen ohne kohle
kein candidate hallo wir sind jahr 2020
heutzutage wird jeder bruder von seiner
kleinen schwester prostituierte so
bekommen in der realität
ok also gibt es ganze projekt daraus
christ dieser typ schild mit irgendeiner
anderen shire und diese muss ich an der
stelle sage für den satz gerade eben
schon kleine hund ist sie dann also
denise wurde komplett abgerückt war 100
euro investiert neue klamotten gekauft
um dann am ende als wahl bezeichnet zu
werden
vielen dank rtl 2 dass ich bei dieser
folge mitspielen durfte wir merken uns
heute wenn es nicht mal im alltag auf
die situation trifft dass jemand den
erkennt seine eigene familie mitglied
für geld anbieten möchte
dann rennt einfach und checkte drüben
ein vorgeschlagenes die araber nicht
hier um einen kanal und hört auf die
taschengeld tabelle des jugendamtes